women
how many men's shelters are there
I could not I've not been to one so I
don't know how many women's shelters are
there what's more common yeah well
Michelle quite a lot yeah yes and so
it's like women are bailed out of every
bad decision that we make always you
know whatever it doesn't matter what bad
decision we make will build out so like
for example as a girl if you want to
sleep around this birth control if you
want if you get pregnant right but men
they don't like they can't opt out of
Child Support
yeah yeah it's not it's not as big in
the in the UK as the US and the US
that's like a bigger issue but you guys
are still like I've interviewed many men
that like basically felt like they were
trapped by a girl because she wanted to
get
um child support on top of that if women
are bad with money
um there's a lot of government programs
we can go on like you're paid to be a
single mom here you get free housing so
you're paid to make a bad decision
housing visit Free Housing a single dad
no no no and that's the thing men pay
into most of these programs so you guys
are literally paying for women's bad
decisions because you guys make more we
spend more even though we make less so
if we're bad if we're bad with money we
end up homeless there's women's shelters
what can we complain as men if we are
the guys implementing this is that
woman's fault well I would I wouldn't
say I wouldn't say that men are
implementing it like it's getting close
to 50 50 about men and women in
government and it's a very small
percentage of men that are implementing
this so it's like it's like the rich
guys you know they're not it doesn't
matter to them but they're just
upholding these days
by our government has been predominantly
male in the past yeah
I don't really know too much about life
who's at the top and [ __ ] I mean
obviously
women quit like that's common
I mean they've all quit they've all quit
now look up the shortest like um terms
in the UK history it's like the only one
that it's all women except for one dude
and he he died it's like women quit it's
true that's two women
of the Margaret fracture that's yeah I
tend to be quitters
Society like men men have to deal with
reality a lot quicker than women do
I think I think oh but you know what I
feel like sorry the woman's full I think
our reality is just
different grow
th you know what I'm saying but that's
what I'm saying really I think it's our
own fault but it's okay what I'm getting
from this is like we did it to ourselves
like all of these like you know kind of
like standards people have men have to
uphold women have to uphold
what I'm hearing right now is that men
chose these things but then then again
you say it didn't matter a small
percentage of men go ahead sorry
small percentage but yeah that's it yeah
we're at fault because I feel like
that's true that we we've created this
problem for ourselves and it's probably
why you see sometimes like obviously
like some men just Unfortunately they
offer themselves in it because of the
pressures that we put on ourselves and
obviously Society you know so uh you
know I feel like we're women like
finding their own or empowering
themselves you know I mean hopefully
that that can alleviate some of the
problems that men face or the pressure
that men take on themselves on that side
no 100 I'm trying to be like stay on
that because
divorce you know yes yeah because the
woman's the owner she's the breadwinner
much more likely to commit men are much
more likely to commit suicide after a
divorce because the thing is women are
paid to take the kids because you get
more child support based on how much you
have the kids so you're incentivized to
not give the dad access to the kids is
it yeah like that's how child support is
calculated and on top of that
um the what will happen is a guy will be
in his 50s and he'll get divorced and
she'll take half and the children and so
to him he has to start over so she makes
money if she makes more money than him
he gets more child support from her now
if he has the kids it's not common it's
not like um the justice system very much
favors women like the women only win 13
of alimony cases
sorry men only win 13 of alimony cases
boyfriend whole time
right now it's uncommon and also men get
uh three times the amount of sentencings
for the same crime as women is it yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah so so if a woman if a
woman kills somebody she's getting three
times this on average or they don't go
to jail at all like homegirl in Miami
yeah but imagine imagine
yeah but imagine if the rules were
reversed would a dude that had just beat
his girlfriend to death be allowed to
walk free for a month before he got
arrested no oh yeah because she uh yeah
had dinner with her mom somewhere else
yeah yeah
and it wasn't until like the the video
footage just started to come out like
that she was abusing him but imagine
like like 20 30 years ago before there
was footage everywhere no one would know
that's true and that's a common story
like well again with like the me too
thing like there's just a lot of common
stories where men have been have really
gotten The Showdown to the stick for a
long time and then the women are the one
like now the women are oh boohoo my
life's so hard stop it
no it's not what I thought I mean
yeah there's other stuff has been still
attracted to women and [ __ ] and you know
I don't think
I don't know I think we've just all been
raised different as you know your
different sets and things like that so a
lot to say like you know women
intentionally make well everyone makes
bad decisions but like men make them too
like they're there as well and women
make them as well but I get what you're
saying where uh there are systems in
place to help
make good decisions I mean I think men
and women are equally shitty I think
people can be shitty but if you pay one
gender to make bad decisions they're
gonna make more bad decisions that's
true like if you if you pay people to be
single mothers there's going to be more
single mothers if you pay women to
divorce and they get half they're going
to do it like if you pay if you allow
women to beat up on men and not and be
able to call the police and blame it on
the guy they're gonna do it if you if
you say believe all women then the
shitty women are gonna do it well yeah
well if we just circle back to the
whales for a second okay
I mean whales are beautiful majestic
creatures
I like that sea life and stuff yeah
you also described you also described
whales as something else was that oh fat
chicks yeah so why why okay okay I'll
tell you how it started
yeah why did you call five six words
okay I'll tell you how it started so it
all started with one day I was doing
interview and shortage
and I I was talking like this woman was
like oh boohoo I can't walk home alone
at night I'm like men can't walk home
alone at night either like when in
history have you been able to just walk
alone at night yeah so you're entitled
to secure that is one thing as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible